[MUSIC PLAYING]
SANDEEP PARIKH:
Welcome, everybody,
to HYB102, Incrementally
Adopting Istio.
My name is Sandeep Parikh.
Unfortunately, my co-presenter
Tahir couldn't be here today.
He ended up not getting
his passport with his visa
back in time to make it all
the way here from Singapore.
So he couldn't make it, but
he was very upset about it.
He had a lot of
good stuff to share.
So we're going to find another
way for him to get some
of the slides that he was
going to present back out
to y'all at another time.
So today, we're going to
cover what, the why, and the
how of Istio.
Due to scheduling, I
think this session would
have been better served
on earlier on Tuesday
before a lot of the
other service mesh
and ACL sessions
that kicked off,
but I don't make
the rules on that.
So we'll have to go talk to
people in marketing about that
later on.
So this is coming.
We're sort of in the middle of
some of the 200 level stuff,
and some of the 300
level things are still
happening tomorrow as well.
But just for my own, actually,
education, I'd love to know,
how many of you,
by show of hands,
have used Istio or
played with Istio at all?
Oh, shit, that's a big number.
What about Istio in Production?
Who's got Istio in Production?
OK.
Awesome.
Very cool.
By the way, I hope you all saw
who raised their hands so you
can go talk to them if
you've got questions
after the talk is over.
All right.
So just a quick
little bit about me.
I'm a developer advocate or
a cloud native advocate--
the title changes all the time--
for Google Cloud.
And before Google, I worked at
MongoDB, and Apple, and a bunch
of other random startups.
You can find me on Twitter or at
GitHub with the same user name.
People always ask.
It's circus monkey,
minus the vowels.
And the content that I'm
going to talk about today
is up in a repo there
as well, and I'll
have the link at the end so
you guys can pull that down.
I'm going to do a
little bit of slides,
and there's a little
bit of demo at the end.
But all the material's actually
a fully baked set of tutorials
you can walk through.
All right.
So let's start with
why Istio, right?
We've just finished kind
of getting into Kubernetes
and be comfortable there.
And now we're going to add
another layer of abstraction
on top of it.
Why do we want to
do this, right?
Why is Istio so critically
useful and important
to deployments?
Right, we have containers.
Containers are great.
We love containers, right?
It lets us be really portable
and get out of this whole,
like, it worked on my
machine, but not over there
in production.
So we can get this sort
of unified environment,
get this great packaging.
Containers, awesome.
Kubernetes, also great, right?
It does a lot of
great things for us.
It orchestrates those
containers really well.
It lets us schedule
amount and bin pack them
very tightly into a cluster.
Really powerful.
But microservices
deployments are hard,
by their just very
nature, right?
You have a bunch of services
strewn across a cluster.
Teams are iterating
at different paces.
You've got dependencies you
don't even know about, right?
Again, spread out
across this whole thing.
Applying policy,
applying control
is challenging in that
environment, right?
Istio helps us get
from that sort of mess
on the left to something
that's more organized
and functional on the right.
If you think about
some of the, again,
that higher level of
abstraction, right?
So we've moved on from
just containers, and pods,
and scheduling them and
deploying them into a cluster.
But again, if you think
about that next level up,
what makes those microservices
deployments hard, right?
So a good example is Canary
releases or doing blue green,
or traffic splitting.
If you want to do that
in Kubernetes today,
you actually have to run
the correct ratio of pods.
So if you wanted to do
something like a 90/10 split
to test out v1 versus
v2, you'd actually
have to run nine pods
of v1 and one pod of v2
to make sure you've
got that 90/10 split.
That's kind of a pain, and
it requires a little too much
handholding to really work well.
You don't really know who
you're talking to, right?
Your services
could have a person
in the middle or a service
in the middle there,
where you could be
opening yourself
up to some kind of
attack or injection.
Right?
You want to make
sure that services
know who they're communicating
with back and forth.
You want to be able to quickly
dig into high latency drivers.
Again, if you think of a
microservices deployment,
you may have a web request
that comes in the frontend,
but it may travel around to
a number of other services.
Well, how do you know
if it's slow, right?
The end user might
feel like, well, this
is taking 500 milliseconds
or over 1,000 milliseconds.
But it might not
be the frontend.
It might be one of
the various backends
that that frontend
is talking to.
And there's a whole host
of other things, right?
Like digging into L7 attributes,
like request headers.
We can't do that right out
of the box in Kubernetes.
You can't really control
who accesses services,
and you can't track requests
from start to finish.
So you don't have a
level of visibility
to match, again, the complexity
of the deployment you're doing.
So that's a little
bit of why we think
Istio is really powerful
because it gives you
access to all of these.
So again, we've talked
about service mesh.
Many of you obviously
have played with this.
[INAUDIBLE] have some
understanding here.
But I'd like to start with this
idea of what is Istio, right?
Istio, if you think of it
and if you boil it down
to its kind of
simplest concept, Istio
is about automation, right?
It goes beyond, I think, just
a sort of a service mesh.
I don't think that
really encapsulates it.
Istio gives you this power
to apply policy and control
to your entire
deployment, whether it's
five services or 500 services.
You can take a single rule and
say, I want to turn on MTLS
and make every service mutually
authenticate to each other
with one rule.
And that goes
cluster wide, right?
Or namespace wide, depending
how you roll it out.
So the three things that
Istio kind of gives you around
in those areas of automation
are, one, very uniform
observability, right?
Metrics logging
tracing right out
of the box, operational
agility, which
is a fancy way of
saying I think a lot
of traffic and
networking control,
and then a very deterministic
policy driven security model.
So if you dig in a
little bit further,
with telemetry, you can
examine all of that traffic
in and out of those services
and out of your cluster
as well with very little to no
instrumentation in many cases,
right?
That's incredibly powerful.
You could take
the responsibility
of adding in things like
latency and tracing outside
of the hands of
developers and say,
you don't have to worry
about instrumenting this
as a starting point.
We'll learn a lot just
by putting this thing
and running it with Istio.
Same thing is true of traffic.
You can take the
networking control outside
of the application.
Make that a loosely
coupled structure.
So applications can be deployed
however they need to be.
Your services can be deployed
in whatever way makes sense.
But then the
cluster operator can
decide how traffic
[INAUDIBLE] should happen,
how rollouts should happen.
And then finally,
security, obviously, right?
Being able to secure access and
communication between services
or add authentication policies
to individual services or all
of them, depending on how
you want to roll it out.
So at a glance, Istio is--
again, it does add
complexity, right?
Where we're sort of
solving complexity
by adding some other complexity.
So that's a little bit
of a tradeoff in terms
of how much it has to happen.
But if you think about it, what
you're effectively trying to do
is, one, narrow the
problem space a little bit.
You're trying to tell
your application teams,
take the complexity
away from them.
You're saying don't worry
about networking control.
Don't worry about some
of the telemetry aspects.
Don't worry about security.
We'll take the complexity
away from them,
and we'll put it on
the cluster operator.
But then we'll give them,
again, that automation
to apply those things in
a much more granular way
and be able to, again,
incrementally roll it out.
So if you start with the
most basic component,
that's the Istio sidecar proxy.
And you'll see that
little hexagon over there.
That's actually the Envoy logo.
So the Istio sidecar is
powered by Envoy, right?
It's effectively
the Envoy proxy.
Envoy's a fantastic project,
fantastic piece of code.
It's very high performance.
And because it lives
in your pod right
alongside your application
container or your services
container, they share
the same network space,
which means it can actually
capture and filter through all
the traffic going in and out.
So it adds a thin
little layer of control
over the traffic going in
and out of your containers.
The next part is I guess what
we call sort of the data plane,
right?
Which things are sort of
generating and pushing data
out or implementing rules?
Again, that's the Envoy
proxy piece itself,
but when you kind of
slice across your cluster,
we consider those proxies
as the, quote unquote, data
plane in the cluster.
And this is something
you can deploy today.
You can take the Envoy
open source proxy
and deploy it as part of your
containers or part of your pods
today.
What's missing is a
central control plane
to deliver rules and
configuration to those proxies.
And that's really
what Istio provides.
It kind of packages this
whole thing up and gives you
a unified control plane
with a series of components
to push rules and
configuration information out.
And so inside of
that control plane,
there's three main
components, right?
And there's actually
a fourth one
I didn't mention
here, galley, which
is responsible for handling
some of the configuration
components.
But the three main
ones that we tend
to deal with on a regular basis
are pilot, mixer, and citadel.
So pilot's responsibility
is taking in the rules
that you give it and
making sure they get
back out to all those proxies.
So at any point in the
lifetime of your cluster
or your deployment, you can see
all of your pods and the rules
that pilot has sent out and
figure out which ones have
synced and which ones haven't,
which ones have gotten
the latest version of the
rules, which ones haven't.
So you have that control there.
Mixer's job is to take metrics
and telemetry data that
come out of those
proxies, and then
send them downstream to
the telemetry backend
of your choice, whether
it's Prometheus,
Grafana, Stackdriver.
You name it.
And the last one, citadel,
is responsible for managing
certificates.
So its job is to
make sure everybody's
got the right
certificates, and keys,
and authentication information.
And it does the magic
of rotating those things
around all on its own.
So that's a little bit of
the components of Istio,
but what does Istio
really do for you, right?
If we get into some
of that detail.
So if we start
with observability,
or observing, as
I mentioned, you
get automatic tracing, logging,
and monitoring by default.
So as long as you send your
logs out to local hosts,
as long as you publish your
metrics at known good end
points, and whether you
do or you don't actually
add any tracing information,
it can actually still
deliver some tracing information
out from your applications.
So those proxies,
they send that tracing
and that telemetry
data to mixer.
And mixer has a
well-formed adapter API
that lets it send all that
data to particular backends.
And you could, again,
split these out.
So you may say, well, if I'm
running in GKE inside of Google
Cloud, maybe I want to
use Stackdriver logging
in Stackdriver trace.
But you really love
Prometheus and Grafana.
By all means, you can
put those two together.
So you can have that mix
of different backends
and components depending
on the piece you want.
You could even have
it so you push metrics
to Prometheus and to
Stackdriver if you wanted to.
There's no real limit to
how you can configure this.
For connecting services,
right, that kind
of operational agility
component is really
where the networking
piece comes in.
There's a few objects that are
really dedicated specifically
to networking inside of Istio.
And those are virtual services,
destination rules, gateways,
and service entries.
And so those, in some
combination of one or more
of those, they let you do things
like traffic splitting, traffic
steering, right, from one
version to another, fault
injection, circuit braking,
and egress control,
which is really powerful, right?
If you have a lot of services
that call external APIs,
this is a really powerful way
to put some control over that,
but more importantly,
as a security mechanism
or to form a better
security posture.
Let's say you have a bad
docker image that you pulled
and deployed, maybe a malformed
tag, or maybe something got
injected into that container.
Well, if you lock
down egress control,
that means nobody
can make outbound API
calls or outbound calls,
unless you've specifically
allowed that service.
So now you're getting just sort
of this free kind of perimeter
around your deployment,
just by having that proxy
and having this
infrastructure in place.
If we dig in a little bit to
some of the traffic splitting
and traffic steering, the
way the Envoy proxy works
is you send rules up to
pilot in that configuration.
Pilot sends those rules to
end those individual proxies.
So now those proxies themselves
know how to route traffic
around from one to the other.
So in the top example, we've
got service A and service
B. Service B has different
versions that that might have.
If you just rely on
Kubernetes routing,
you get round robin
routing, right?
So you basically get
an equivalent amount
of requests spread across here.
So in the example, in the
right side and the upper right
there example, you might see
like 25% going to each pod.
With Istio, we can
actually control this
and say, well, we want 95 and 5.
We want to have a canary version
that we roll out very slowly.
On the bottom
example, that's really
where we get into things
like traffic steering.
Again, because of
the way Envoy works,
it can actually
inspect the headers
coming in to your applications.
So that means that
we can actually
say based on maybe
a header value,
I might want to direct traffic
to a particular version
or particular pod.
So for example,
you could say, hey,
for logged in users running on
iOS with WebKit version xyz,
direct them to this
canary rollout test
or this other version
of that service.
So you have that
level of control
that you didn't
have just, again,
with sort of vanilla Kubernetes.
And as I mentioned
earlier, you can also
inject things along the way.
And these are really
not necessarily things
you're going to use in a
production environment,
but for more of a testing
and resiliency perspective.
You may want to inject things
like delay, sort of retries,
or even other connection rules.
Circuit breaker
is a good example.
You can inject a
circuit breaker inside
of this path between services,
and control whether you want
cascade failures to happen.
Or if requests
start to fail, just
cut off access immediately.
So your end users aren't seeing
high latency waiting for errors
to time out all the way through.
And as with a lot of
the way Istio works,
those rules can match
very particular conditions
and be directed at a
percentage of requests,
not all requests or just some.
So you have, again,
very granular control
that you can really implement
across your platform.
On the security front,
four main components that
really stand out, right?
Encrypting traffic
between services,
authenticating services or
service authentication--
service to service,
I should say--
auditing control, and access
control policies, right?
Again, very powerful stuff.
Think of it this way.
I can implement--
again, mutual TLS
is a good example
and actually one
that a customer came to us with.
They were told by one of
their downstream customers
that they needed to encrypt
traffic between all services.
And Istio was the fastest
way for them to get there.
Because they redeployed their
pods with the sidecar proxy
and then flipped a
bit with one rule
to turn on mutual authentication
across everything there.
And that's really powerful.
The security model--
this diagram's
a little bit hard to
read in a few spots.
The point is it's kind
of rolling together
all of the security parts
of the infrastructure
that you can kind of
inject along the way.
So requests are coming
in on the far left
and sort of traversing through
to the far right on the egress
side.
And you can see where citadels
issuing certificates, where
things like service
authentication maybe
with job tokens or MTLS
between services is happening.
So you have, again,
this level of control
that's not really possible
without another higher level
tool.
So that's a little bit of
the background of the why
and sort of the what of Istio.
But how do you put Istio to
work for yourself, right?
This is where I want to get
to this idea of incrementally
rolling it out.
Because like with
any new technology,
you don't honestly
want to start and go
from zero to 100% on day one.
You want to find the features
that make the most sense,
and then start rolling
those out bit by bit.
So the easiest way to get
started with Istio is actually,
we built something inside
of Google Kubernetes
Engine, a little
add-on that lets
you deploy Istio
by default or along
with your cluster deployment.
So using either G Cloud
or the Cloud console,
you can actually spin
up a Kubernetes cluster.
And there's a little section
called add-ons, and just
check the box for Istio.
And then pick a security
approach, whether you
want permissive or strict.
And for the purposes
of this example,
I used MTLS permissive,
just to make
things a little bit easier.
But that's something
I started with here.
So this is an easy
way to get Istio.
But frankly, installing
the OSS version
is not that terribly
challenging either, right?
Grab the latest release.
Apply it via the Helm chart,
and you're off and running.
And with the Helm chart, you
get the level of customizability
you might want.
So for example, maybe
you decide today, I only
really care about telemetry.
Only get the components
that worry about telemetry.
Don't worry about having
the traffic components
or the security components.
You can always upgrade to
that later on using Helm.
So Helm gives you that
power of flexibility.
And there's also a quick
start inside the Istio repo
as well that just
deploys everything.
So you have a couple
of different options
for how to get the software
running inside of your cluster.
Once you do this and once
this cluster comes up,
you end up with a bunch of pods
running inside the Istio system
namespace.
And again, it's
all those things we
saw earlier-- pilot, citadel,
galley, among other things
depending on which
version you installed, OSS
or whether you're using the
one we package here for you.
If you use this version, we
install all the Stackdriver
adapters for you by
default. If you use OSS,
it comes with Prometheus
and Grafana out of the box.
So you have a couple of
different options there.
But once you've got this up
and running, once the system is
ready, you can actually start
to include the sidecar proxy
inside of your pods.
And there's two ways to do it.
The bottom way is the
way we see a lot of folks
do it, which is basically
taking a namespace and saying,
anything that gets deployed
to that namespace, by default,
just auto inject
to sidecar proxy.
Or you have the other
approach of saying, well,
I'm going to do it on a
per sort of YAML basis.
Every time I push
a new service, I'm
going to filter my YAML
through this Istio control
binary that adds in
the appropriate piece
to your pod spec.
So it includes a sidecar proxy.
So there's a couple
different ways to kind of get
started there.
But if you're rolling
it out, what I would say
is don't start with
auto injection, right?
You don't want the
pod out right yet.
Again, it really comes
down to the features
that you're most interested in.
The other thing I
would also say--
and I mentioned
this a bit earlier--
is start with permissive MTLS.
You can always turn it on later.
But when you first turn it
on, if you go with strict,
it might start to break things.
So you might want
to roll it out,
again, on a case by case or
service by service basis.
So that's just a little
bit of getting started.
Let's go through a couple
of or a few example kind
of incremental rollouts, right?
Then again, think of
the state of the cluster
as we've got Istio
up and running.
We're not auto injecting
the sidecar proxy yet.
So for traffic management,
let's say you've
got a simple deployment here.
And I wrote a little sample
app called Weather Info
because I was getting really
tired of the built-in Bookinfo.
I just decided to
make another one.
And it's got a frontend and
two different backends, right?
This just pulls the weather
from an external API.
v1 pulls it from a single city.
And v2 pulls it for four cities
and just displays it out,
so nothing fancy.
But let's say we want to
roll this out in a way,
again, using Istio
incrementally,
but we still want
to take advantage
of some of the traffic
features that are available.
So how do we do that?
Right?
Quick recap on traffic
splitting just to remember,
just to remind y'all.
Right?
We will have this
approach where we
want to try to get this 95/5.
Now the difference here is
that all of these examples,
they've got the
sidecar proxy in them.
So the question is-- and this
is the question I asked myself
about six months ago--
how can I do this kind
of traffic splitting
without having to roll
the sidecar proxy out?
It turns out there's a little
bit of a cheat and a way
to do it.
It's not initially the way I
would recommend for everything,
especially for full blown
kind of large scale production
deployments.
But as you're testing
things out and getting
acquainted with the
rules and infrastructure,
it's a way to kind of play
with the networking APIs
before, again, you
go wide with it.
So what we're going
to try to do here,
our goal is to get to 90/10.
And remember, without Istio,
right, without anything
by default, Kubernetes will
just do round robin 50/50
across both of these.
So that's where
we're starting from.
We're starting from 50/50.
Now this little box
there is Istio, right?
And I've got a little
ingress gateway
that's allowing inbound
traffic at the top.
So for us to get
to this, there's
a few components we have
to deploy to make it work.
So using our virtual service
and a destination rule,
we can actually direct
traffic from weather frontend
to weather backend v1
at 90% and v2 at 10%
by directing traffic
through the ingress gateway.
So again, rolling it
out a little bit slowly,
but getting a chance
to test this out
in kind of a measured approach.
So the traffic
policy we want to do
for this is the
first thing we do
is create a destination rule.
And as you can
imagine by the name,
a destination rule kind of tells
inbound traffic where to go.
So it's saying I want
to direct traffic
to these possible subsets.
So in this example, all
the destination rule
is really saying is create
some subsets of my service.
In this case,
single and multiple
is what I call them, right?
So we've got a subset for single
and a subset for multiple.
I just want to have
those on record
as being things I can
direct traffic to later on.
And then we create
the gateway component.
We connect the gateway to the
rest of the infrastructure.
So what we're
saying here is we're
going to open up a
port 80 on the gateway.
We're going to do
it for all hosts.
Again, this is just
a demo example.
I wouldn't do this
in real world.
in production.
All we're telling
you here is we're
going to set up a gateway
connected to the Istio ingress
gateway that comes with Istio
by default, which is just
another Envoy proxy.
And we're going to tell
it to open up port 80.
And then we can actually
create a virtual service
that tells requests when they
get to the ingress gateway
where to direct them to.
So remember, we had
those named subsets
of single and multiple
a couple of slides back.
So here, we can call
it out specifically.
We attach this virtual
service to that gateway
we just created.
We match on a very particular
endpoint-- in this case,
/api/weather.
And then we tell
it to just traffic
split those two across
the single version
and the multiple version
at a 90/10 split.
So that's it.
We're done.
Any traffic coming in
through that ingress gateway
is now going to go
across those two subsets.
So that's good.
We've solved some of the basic
traffic splitting problem,
but we haven't actually
connected the weather frontend
component to it yet.
So the last step in that process
is to update the deployment.
All we're changing here is we're
changing the backend location.
So this is actually in the
weather frontend deployment
spec for the component's
frontend Kubernetes.
All it did was change the
hostname of where it's
supposed to send traffic to.
Now it's going to send it
through the Istio ingress
gateway instead.
So really, the only service
that had to change here,
that had to be
redeployed, if you will,
was the weather
frontend component.
Once you push this
out, all the traffic
will now start to go
through that other piece,
the ingress gateway.
And then it will
get split there.
So we did this without
deploying any Envoy proxies
across those pods
that were there.
Again, the nice
way to do this is--
or the nice thing about
this is that you're not
having to redeploy or
update infrastructure.
You're not having to
inject a sidecar quite yet.
And it's a good
way to sort of test
and get familiarity
with the components,
with the APIs that
are available to you.
But that's one example of
just kind of rolling it out.
What about security?
How do you roll out security
in a measured and controlled
manner?
So in this case, we
are going to have
to have injection
turnout because really,
at the end of the day, for you
to make use of any security
infrastructure, you've got to
have the sidecar proxy included
in those pods to
enforce those policies.
So here, what we
did is we've got
two namespaces in
our cluster, one
I called legacy, which
is some vanilla service,
and one called secure.
And in the secure
namespace, I have Istio
and auto injection turned on.
So that means when I
deployed weather frontend,
weather backend, they got the
Envoy proxy in those pods.
So now what we want to do is we
want to slowly roll out MTLS.
We want to roll it out so
we secure the infrastructure
in the secure namespace.
And we want to allow traffic
from the legacy namespace.
So the first thing we do
after we get these services up
and running is start
with a security policy.
And for those of you that are
paying really close attention,
I had to shorten the
names of the API versions
to fit on the slide.
So if you happen to
look at these later on,
don't copy from here.
Copy from the GitHub repo.
That actually has the
correct YAML specified there.
But here, what we did is we're
setting up the backend service.
We're turning on a policy
there for security.
We're saying we want it to
have a permissive policy so
that anybody can connect to
it from within that cluster.
So the net effect is
that this service now
has access to connect here.
Right?
So now it has a permissive
policy you can connect.
And weather frontend was
not impacted by this.
It was because it's got
the Envoy proxy already.
It can already connect to it.
And now what we can do is
apply a destination rule
that's saying anybody that's got
the proxy as part of their pod
can use mutual authentication.
So what this is doing is,
again, slowly rolling out
MTLS to all the services that
can take advantage of it.
So this destination
rule, all it says
is use the Istio mutual mode.
That means if you are
capable of doing MTLS,
let's go ahead and do it.
So the net effect
there is that now we've
got mutual TLS happening between
frontend and the backend,
but still maintaining permissive
access to weather backend.
By the way, and that rule was
kind of under specified, right?
I left it a little bit open
about who could connect to it.
You can actually get
way more fine grained
and say only
certain services can
utilize that permissive mode.
So you have that
ability to control
at a very fine grained
level about who
can access that thing without
using mutual authentication.
But now what were to happen
if we turn on strict, right?
If we take it from a permissive
mode or mutual mode to strict,
right?
Once we implement this
policy and update that policy
from saying permissive to
strict, that means anybody that
doesn't have the proxy
that can't do MTLS
won't be able to
connect to this.
Because what they're
missing are the certificates
from things like citadel and
the configuration from galley
to make it work.
So this is an easy way to
start with-- right, again,
remember the cluster we deployed
was set to permissive mode.
So that was already
kind of an open setup.
But with mutual, we actually
able to turn on MTLS again
on that service
by service basis.
And anybody that could
do it would use it.
And then once we
transitioned to strict,
we cut off access
to legacy clients.
So this is a good way to think
about-- again, it's a demo
and I couldn't fit that
much information on a slide,
but think about how you
might, again, slowly
roll this kind of thing
out across a larger
environment, right?
If you map this kind of problem
to 5, 500, 1,000 services,
it's an easy way to enforce
policy and enforce security
very quickly and to
start encrypting traffic
between services immediately.
So that was an incremental
rollout of security.
What about telemetry, right?
This is another, I
think, key feature
of Istio, where, again,
you get that monitoring
and that tracing and
logging for free.
And I mentioned this
a little bit earlier,
but I love hitting
it as much as I can.
Without additional
instrumentation,
you get this output directed
to your choice of backend.
So what are some of the metrics
that you get by default,
that you get for free?
So you get things like request
count, request duration.
Particularly for
HTTP, you get things
like size of request body,
the response body size.
And then for TCP services,
you get additional information
like bytes sent, bytes received.
And this is actually a first
source and destination as well,
so you get variations for both.
So you can actually
track, again,
traffic inbound to your
pod, traffic outbound.
And control and
understand the telemetry
and what's happening there.
So these metrics just
start getting published.
And again, in open source Istio,
they go straight to Prometheus.
In the version that you
can install directly
through the GKE console, they
go straight to Stackdriver.
That's it.
So at this point, what I'd like
to do is switch to the demo.
Can everybody read that OK?
Or is that big enough?
Right, no one's a no.
So let's see.
We're going to make sure we're
on the right cluster here.
So I'm in my hybrid 102 cluster.
And we can show you
what's running on here.
So I've got that
example app I talked
about before, the
weather frontend
with the weather backend single,
weather backend multiple.
And I've got a
little low generator
script that's generating
and pushing traffic through.
And so what I wanted
to show you first
is the Stackdriver
Trace component.
So again, I didn't change
anything in my code.
I didn't instrument.
I didn't add anything to it.
All I did is turned on Istio,
deployed those containers
with the sidecar
proxy auto injected,
and then I started sending
data to Stackdriver Trace
immediately.
And so I just did
this earlier today
so that doesn't have an
automatic report there,
but we can actually dig
in a little bit further.
So this is a
Stackdriver trace UI.
It will by default
give you things
like insights over
the last seven days,
or it'll create some auto
analysis reports for you.
Or you can actually just
dig into individual URLs
or requests yourself.
So if I go over here
to the trace list,
I can actually look and see--
I can look at the latency of
the requests that are coming in.
Again, everything is being
generated by that load
generator script right now.
But actually, drag along
here and figure out.
So let's pick this
little section there.
I had a couple of high requests.
So I can look here and say
I've got a request that
was 301 milliseconds.
If I dig into that
one completely, one,
I get this timeline, so I
can see again the request
and how long it took.
And then over here
on the right, I
get a lot more detail about
things like the timestamp.
And then I get to see things
like where it came from.
And I think that's where
it's really important.
I can actually go here and
say the source workload was
weather frontend, right?
The URL was API weather.
This agent that's
using the track
is the agent that's built
into the sidecar proxy
or built into
mixer, I should say.
And where that
traffic was going.
So we get some level
of detail here.
I can also filter and go back.
And let's say I want to just
look at the external API
calls I'm making to
the weather map API.
So I can say Sent.api and
filter requests there.
And now here I can see
that most of my requests
are staying in this under
50 milliseconds boundary.
But we've got a couple that
have taken a little bit longer.
And we can see,
again, the timeline
it took for that
request to go out
and the workload that
that came from, right?
So in this case, it
came from the weather
backend multiple service.
And here's the actual
URL it was requesting.
And I didn't add
any tracing here.
So I haven't done anything
to my code to enable this.
Now as you can
probably imagine, this
isn't telling me a whole heck
of a lot of information, right?
Because Envoy can
track those requests
from one proxy to another,
it's capable of showing
you this data.
If you want to get that
next level of information,
if you want to know, well,
once it enters that request,
once that request hits one
of my methods in my code,
I want to know which line or
which section of that code
is taking a long time.
If you want that
level of detail,
you'll have to actually
go in and instrument.
And you'll have your choice
of different instrumentation
libraries, like either
Zipkin or OpenCensus,
depending on which one makes
the most sense for you.
But once you have that
level of instrumentation,
what you would actually see here
is a much more granular kind
of bar graph of the different
sections of your code
or how long they took.
So you get a much
better and clearer idea
of what's actually
happening across there.
The nice thing about
that is you don't only
have to add the tracing
statements into your code.
You don't actually to worry
about where to send it.
Because again, the proxy
is capturing that tracing
reporting data on its way out.
And it's actually
forwarding it on the mixer,
and the mixer is actually
posting it to the backend.
So that's a quick run through
of the tracing components
here, instead of
Stackdriver Trace.
Let me quickly show
you all what it
looks like if you were to
look at the open source
Prometheus and Grafana.
So let me just quickly forward
the port over from Prometheus.
And I'm doing this from a
different cluster that's
running in another project.
All right, so that's
forwarding across.
We can open up Prometheus now.
And inside Prometheus,
if you've ever
seen the sort of default
Prometheus piece here,
you can actually start
filtering by Istio metrics.
So you can look at sort
of Istio total requests.
Which is not very
exciting, right,
looking through all this.
It's a lot of information
and a lot of data.
It's not really sort of
eminently visible by default
here, even if you
kind of graph it out.
What's nicer is when you
dig into it using Grafana.
So the Prometheus and Grafana
that come with OSS Istio
are pre-configured to be tightly
coupled and worked together.
So Grafana is already pulling
data right off that Prometheus
instance.
So if I do the same thing here,
but change that port forwarding
to Grafana, you can actually
see a lot of interesting metrics
in Grafana as well.
The other nice thing about
the instance of Grafana
that we package in for you is
that it comes with some canned
Istio specific dashboards.
So once you load the Grafana
on the main dashboard,
you go over to kind of
the manage section, which
is what I did.
And there should be
an Istio folder there.
You can open that Istio folder.
And now we can
actually start to say,
well, I want to dig into
the service dashboard
in particular.
Inside the service
dashboard, right, it
opens with any of the
services that I'm calling.
So because I have a service
entry inside of Istio
for api.openweathermap.org,
it creates
a service entry for that
here so I can browse by that.
So I can actually see the client
request volume, the success
rate.
This one's not that interesting.
But if we look at
the weather backend,
that gets little bit
more interesting, right?
We could see the request
volume, the success rate.
And if we continue on down,
incoming requests and response
code, right?
The success rate or the
duration for some of these
calls, again,
highlighting our ability
to dig into these calls
that might be taking
quite a long time, right?
This one is showing us
that that 99th percentile,
it's returning about
950 milliseconds,
which is quite a bit.
And there's some TCP
specific ones here
that aren't filled in as well.
Same thing is true again
of the weather frontend.
You can see those
dashboards and look
at that traffic information.
Or you can switch to the--
let's see, where is the
Istio workload dashboard?
Right?
Another way to kind of look
at the information here.
So we'll switch to
the default namespace.
And we'll look at
weather backend multiple.
Let's pick on just
one of those services.
So again, we can see how
long things are taking,
the duration by source,
response size, et cetera.
And we can see all the outbound
and outgoing requests as well.
So this is built in, right?
All those metrics I
mentioned earlier,
those things automatically
captured by Envoy,
Envoy collects that telemetry
and then sends it off to Mixer.
Mixer forwards it on from you.
And if you remember the
Istio at a glance image,
right, there's a lot of
control plane components.
And they function
very much the same
as the Kubernetes
control plane does.
If one of those pieces goes
down for some unspecified amount
of time, you're not locked out
of the traffic routing, right?
You might not be able to push
any new rules or new policies
while maybe pilot is down, but
the rules that were already
pushed out and in
place, those are still
being honored by Envoy.
Just like if you lose
the Kubernetes API
master for a certain
amount of time,
your pods and your
containers are OK.
You just can't
schedule anything new.
So you've got a little
bit of a window of time
before things really turn
ugly to fix things up.
And particularly in the case of
telemetry, if Mixer goes down
or if you lose access
to that Mixer component,
Envoy will actually
retry to send telemetry.
So you won't have these
dropouts over time of metrics
missing because Mixer wasn't
available for some bit there.
So can we switch
back to the slides?
Perfect.
All right, so where
do you go from here?
Right?
We have a couple of examples
or a few examples of how
you can roll Istio out
in a slow measured manner
across an existing
infrastructure, existing
cluster.
And I would say that the
two features that stand out
among what we hear from
customers and users
in the ecosystem are
telemetry and security, right?
Folks really love the ability
to sort of deploy Istio
and then get this telemetry
information very quickly.
Because it's quite a bit to be
able to use right off the bat.
And they also love the
security aspect, right?
Those two features
alone, I think,
are enough to make
Istio worth it.
So what I would
challenge you to do
is think about if Istio
makes sense for you
in a production workload,
figure out which of those things
makes sense.
Do you want it for traffic,
telemetry, security?
And then spend
enough time where you
feel comfortable with
those APIs before you
start rolling it out.
And do it again in that
incremental fashion, right?
You can actually roll things
out and say, well, we're
going to deploy it not
to the default namespace.
We'll do it to a
separate namespace.
And we'll try things out
there before we roll it out
to default or to other
ones, where you might
have production workloads.
Some light reading
to get you started.
Megan actually, who was the
previous speaker in this room,
gave--
both of us worked together on
a series of blog posts called
the Service Mesh Era.
And they're good
conceptual overviews,
but they've actually
got practical tutorials
built in to each one of those.
And they go through
a lot more depth
here around traffic
splitting, canary rollouts,
telemetry stuff, the
security one as well.
And actually, the
last one in the series
focuses on some more
advanced topics in Istio,
like mesh expansion,
adding in VMs, right?
We have a lot of workloads
that still exist on VMs.
I know I went very
Kubernetes centric here,
but we want to make VMs
just as easy as we want
to make it with containers.
So you can deploy and expand
your mesh now with VMs,
but it's still a
little bit more work.
It's not as easy as just
injecting the sidecar.
But she's got a
great example there.
And then there's also
examples of running
Istio in a multi-cluster
deployment,
whether you have a single
control plane in one cluster,
or you have multiple
control planes.
So you can have either one
or both of those setups.
So that's a great series.
I would definitely advise
you to take a look at that.
And then the traffic portion
of this came from a blog post
that I wrote a few months
ago called incremental Istio
with traffic management.
So that's another good example.
It goes into a little more depth
of how you could roll it out.
There's also great
talks on MTLS migration
and some of the
conceptual things.
The last two links are links
to my personal GitHub, where
I have that weather info
app if you want to just have
a quick little example.
Again, I like that
one, because it
requires you to make that
service entry for outbound API
access.
And it's got a couple other
nice little components in there
to try out.
And then all the
stuff I went through,
all that YAML that I truncated
in a couple of slides,
is actually in this repo,
Next 19 Incremental Istio.
So it's all there if you
want to run through this end
to end and roll out traffic
slowly or roll out some
of the security stuff slowly.
There's a fully
baked example there.
Before I close out, I do want to
mention a few other talks that
are happening tomorrow.
There's a little bit
more 200 and 300 level.
But I think they're really good.
Tomorrow morning,
actually, Megan and I
are going to give a talk on
how to debug your deployments
inside of Istio, right?
So this is an example
of you deployed Istio,
you deployed your services
with the sidecar proxy,
and something broke, right?
And we're going to take you
through three or four examples
of things like how do I debug
traffic deployments or traffic
errors, how do I debug
telemetry, right?
What if you have custom metrics?
How do you get those to show
up inside that Prometheus
that you've got as part
of open source Istio?
And the last one
is security one.
We're going to go
through, I think,
some work with MTLS
and job tokens as well.
So that's very much a demo
centric specific exercise
for debugging or
troubleshooting, I should say.
But then we've got a
few other ones as well.
Particularly, I mentioned
the adding Istio for VMs
and expanding the service mesh.
So that's tomorrow as well.
Second to last but not least,
we would love your feedback
about how to make a better
service mesh product, right?
We love the input
from people who
are using Istio, who are
playing with Istio, who
are interested in using Istio.
Why?
What drives that, right?
We want to help improve
as much as we can.
So this is feedback
that we use to make
the commercial version better,
as well as the open source
version.
So by all means, sign up.
Fill out this form.
We'd love your
feedback and your help.
And then finally, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]